do you ever have fans that
are emotional or talk to you about like
how it changed their life or it meant so
much to them because I have that which
is pretty freaking um profound to have
someone say you know your show saved me
I'm like come on I mean I know the the
song on the show was somebody saved me
but like how did how did a a show like
this save you you know in my mind I
don't say it like come on what's wrong
with you but like when they start
telling me like this is what my dad and
I watched and my dad passed but I always
had these memories and when I went
through a hard time I'd go back and I'd
watch these and whatever it was and it
just like blew me away how something
that seems so trivial um you know we get
paid to make pretend and and then people
coming up to you and saying these things
it really had an impact on me and it
still has an impact but I'm sure you
you've gotten
that 100% um and it is a lot of uh
parents and children children or some
people whove lost um significant people
in their life and that would enjoy a
show together um
and and and and also you know being a
part of a of something that was rooted
in grief you know that you know while
some I think could argue Ro that it was
rooted in love A lot of it was rooted in
grief and loss so I get that a lot
um
and and also I totally get it you know
like I um I gosh what I I told this I
was at the airport this like two years
ago and I I was and there was someone
walking by she was a a flight attendant
and she came back with someone else like
one of her
co-workers and she just started crying
about like this loss that she had
experienced in her life and she had
gotten so depressed and a relationship
that had ended and and she just started
to cry and said you know she was so
alone and she but she could watch you
know a show every single night and know
that like she could come home to that
and then I start crying because I said
and she's like I know you probably think
I sound crazy I'm like no you're not
crazy at all um I have the same thing
like I have those same feelings and I
have show that I'm come home to and that
I know if I need to cry or if I need to
laugh or I like bouts of insomnia that I
can just like leave my computer on and
it plays in the background and and so um
and I've also learned that like I feel
really grateful to have learned like
that it's such a waste of time to be
cool like all the cool people in the
world are really like the fans you know
what I mean like people who are willing
to be ftic about something that they
love that's cool and without any shame
or like guilt or like like like this is
embarrassing no it's not like it
shouldn't be embarrassing to like
celebrate something that brings you Joy
that should not be embar like and I'm
talking about very simple things you
know what I like but things that are
like a a show or a movie or a universe
of or a book character or a book or an a
musical artist you know like that's okay
and it makes you feel like you're doing
your job I mean know a lot of times we
do I mean look I I've done a lot of
man I mean just when and I call it
like not not good you know product out
there and I've done some great stuff and
some but that's it's called a job you're
working it's a job but sometimes you do
something that yeah sometimes you do
something that impacts people and I
think it's great